you can't defeat me
shall we after you
[Applause]
thank you
sorry guys for is back and you cut your
hair looks good on you
how are you thank you team
I want to get a closer look at this
fused with intergalactic extras that'll
blow Wow
amen my name is cool what's this guy
again deleted scenes gadreel
and an exclusive short team Darryl Oh
the Grandmaster was the only one who
answered my Craigslist ad yeah - or the
most fun you'll ever have at a Marvel
movie
Marvel's Thor Ragnarok everything is
different and new and fresh and what
drew my interest was knowing that Chris
was gonna be in the film obviously not
just because he's attractive cute he's
cute cute he's cute his Christmas fun to
be around he's a funny guy I've never
met a more generous performer than Chris
he's incredible to work with he holds
this that whole behemoth together like a
lot of us are riding on his shoulders
and what shoulders they are he destroys
the idea of what audiences expect from
him as an actor
to have this villain s be introduced in
such a strong way is really exciting
I've had incredible fun playing with her
because I think her capabilities are so
surprising and so unusual she's not
simply sinister actually
as somebody who's played the villain in
these films I understand the
responsibility is that she has a huge
presence which she can express
physically or verbally she just has this
off-kilter movement to her character I
was completely blindsided by some of the
happiest times have been Marvel study
studio
[Music]
hello my name is Tiger ycg director
actor welcome to thor ragnarok hi guess
humor it's so particular and unique and
quirky all of these tiny little things
hanging washing on electrical cables
that's exactly what we do on earth I'm
into the story a day on the set working
with tyka involves high jinks
dancing day is just a big kid we like
that the whole time college is cracking
up on SEC staff later the most
light-hearted fun set I've been on
scrapper 142 to 114 tooth scrapper
[Music]
look at this world of amazement here
through this door pop Australia
[Music]
it's a Korean Radio Shack so carryin
Walkman the Korean iPod the Korean
Plumbing Supplies
it's justly like Earth
Plumbing Supplies
[Music]
that is how you make movies
[Music]
you